this triangle that we have right over
here is a right triangle and it's a
right triangle because it has a 90
degree angle or it has a right angle in
it
now we call the longest side of a right
triangle we call that side and you can
either view it as the longest side of
the right triangle or the side opposite
the 90 degree angle it is called the
hypotenuse
it's a very fancy word for a fairly
simple idea just the longest side of a
right triangle or the side opposite the
90 degree angle and it's just good to
know that because someone might say
hypotenuse you're like oh they're just
talking about this side right here the
side longest the the side opposite the
90 degree angle
now what i want to do in this video is
prove a relationship a very famous
relationship and you might see where
this is going a very famous relationship
between the lengths of the sides of the
right triangle so let's say that the
length of ac so uppercase a uppercase c
let's call that length lowercase a let's
call the length of bc lower case b right
over here i'll use upper cases for
points lower cases for lengths and let's
call the length of the hypotenuse the
length of a b let's call that c and
let's see if we can come up with a
relationship between a b and c
and to do that i'm first going to
construct another line or another
segment i should say between c and the
hypotenuse and i'm going to construct it
so that they intersect at a right angle
you can always do that and we'll call
this point right over here we'll call
this point capital d and if you're
wondering how can i how can you always
do that you can imagine rotating this
entire triangle like this and this isn't
a rigorous proof but it just kind of
gives you the general idea of how you
can always construct a point like this
so if i've rotated it around so now our
hypotenuse we're now sitting on our
hypotenuse this is point this is now
point b
this is point a so we've rotated the
whole thing all the way around this is
point to c you can imagine just dropping
a rock from point c with maybe with a
string attached and it would hit the
hypotenuse at a right angle so that's
all we did here to establish segment cd
into where we put our point d right over
there and the reason why i did that is
now we can do all sorts of interesting
relationships between similar triangles
because we have three triangles here we
have triangle adc we have triangle dbc
and then we have the larger original
triangle we can hopefully establish
similarity between those triangles and
first i'll show you
that adc is similar to the larger one
because both of them have a right angle
adc has a right angle right over here
clearly if this angle is 90 degrees then
this angle is going to be 90 degrees as
well they're supplementary they have to
add up to 180 and so they both have a
right angle in them so the smaller one
has a right angle the larger one clearly
has a right angle that's where we
started from and they also both share
they also both share this angle right
over here angle dac or bac however you
want to refer to it so we can actually
write down that triangle
i'm going to start with the smaller one
adc
and maybe i'll shade it in right over
here so this is the triangle we're
talking about triangle adc and i went
from the blue angle to the right angle
to the unlabeled angle from the point of
view of triangle adc this right angle
isn't isn't applying to that right over
there it's applying to the larger
triangle so we can say triangle adc
triangle a
dc
is similar
is similar to triangle
once again you want to start at the blue
angle a
then we went to the right angle so we
want to go to the right angle again to
triangle so it's a c b
a
c b
and because they're similar we can set
up a relationship between the ratios of
their sides for example we know the
ratio of corresponding sides are going
to well in general for a similar
triangle we know the ratio of the
corresponding sides are going to be a
constant so we could take the ratio of
the hypotenuse of this side right of the
smaller triangle so the hypotenuse is ac
so ac over the hypotenuse over the
larger one which is a b
a c over a b
is going to be the same thing as
as a d as one of this of one of the legs
a d
a d then just to show that i'm just
taking corresponding points on both
similar triangles this is a d
a d over a c
over a c you can look at these triangles
yourself and show look a d
point a d is between the blue angle and
the right angle and point sorry side a d
is between the blue angle and the right
angle side ac is between the blue angle
and the right angle on the larger
triangle so both of these are from the
larger triangle these are the
corresponding sides on the smaller
triangle and if that is confusing
looking at them visually you can as long
as we wrote our similarity statement
correctly you can just find the
corresponding points ac
corresponds to a b on the larger
triangle a d on the smaller triangle
corresponds to a c on the larger
triangle
and we know that ac we can rewrite that
as lower case a ac is lower case a
ac is lowercase a we don't have any
label for ad or for
for a b
or sorry we do have a label for a b
that is c right over here we don't have
a label for a d so let's just call that
so a d let's just call that lowercase d
so lowercase d applies to
that part right over there c applies to
that entire part right over there
and then we'll call db let's call that
length e that'll just make things a
little bit simpler for us so a d we'll
just call d
and so we have a over c is equal to d
over a if we cross multiply you have a
times a which is a squared is equal to c
times d which is c d so that's a little
bit of an interesting result let's see
what we can do with the other triangle
right over here
so this triangle right over here so once
again it has a right angle the larger
one has a right angle and they both
share this angle right over here so by
angle angle similarity the two triangles
are going to be similar so we could say
triangle b d c we went from pink to
right to not labeled so triangle b
b
d c
triangle b d c is similar to triangle
now we're going to look at the larger
triangle we're going to start at the
pink angle b
and then we'll go to the right angle c
a
b
c a from right a from pink angle to
right angle to non-labeled angle at
least from the point of view here we
labeled it before with that blue so now
let's set up some type of relationship
here we can say that the ratio on the
smaller triangle b
c side bc
over b a
bc over ba once we're again we're taking
the
the hypotenuses of both of them so bc
over ba
is going to be equal to
bd
let me just in another color bd so this
is one of the legs bd the way i drew is
the shorter legs
bd
over bc i'm just taking corresponding
vertices
over bc and once again we know bc is the
same thing as lowercase b
bc is lowercase b b a is lowercase c
ba is lowercase c and then bd we defined
as lowercase e
so this is lowercase e we can cross
multiply here and we get b times b
which and i've mentioned this in many
videos cross multiplying is really the
same thing as multiplying both sides by
both denominators b times b is b squared
is equal to c e
c e
and now we can do something kind of
interesting we can add these two
statements let me rewrite the statement
down here so b squared is equal to c e
so if we add the left hand sides we get
a squared
plus b squared
a squared plus b squared is equal to
c d
is equal to c d
plus c e
plus ce
and then we have a c in both of these
terms so we can factor it out so this is
going to be equal to
we can factor out this c it's going to
be equal to c times d plus e
c times d
plus e
plus e and close the parentheses
now what is d plus e
d is this length e is this length so d
plus e is actually going to be c as well
so this is going to be c so you have c
times c which is just the same thing as
c squared so now we have an interesting
relationship we have that a squared plus
b squared is equal to c squared let me
rewrite that a squared i'll do that well
let me just send an arbitrary new color
actually let me let me i deleted that by
accident so let me rewrite it
so we've just established that a squared
plus b squared is equal to c squared and
this is just an arbitrary right triangle
this is true for any two right triangles
we've just established that the sum of
the squares of each of the legs is equal
to the square of the hypotenuse and this
is probably one of the well it's easily
one of the most famous theorems in
mathematics
named for pythagoras not clear if he's
the first person to establish this
but it's called the pythagorean theorem
pythagorean
pythagorean theorem
theorem
and it's really the basis of well not
all of geometry but a lot of the
geometry that we're going to do and it
forms the basis of a lot of the
trigonometry we're going to do and it's
a really useful way if you know two of
the sides of a right triangle you can
always find the third